The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right,
let's get started.
Today, we have another cool
graph algorithm or problem.
Actually, we'll
have two algorithms.
The problem is called
minimum spanning tree.
You can probably guess from the
title what it's trying to do.
We'll see two
algorithms for doing it.
Both of them are in the category
of greedy algorithms, which
is something we've
seen a couple of times
already in 6.046,
starting with lecture 1.
This is the definition of
greedy algorithm from lecture 1,
roughly.
The idea is to always make
greedy choices, meaning
the choice is locally best.
For right now, it seems
like a good thing to do,
but maybe in the future
it will screw you over.
And if you have a
correct greedy algorithm,
you prove that it
won't screw you over.
So it's sort of like
Cookie Monster here, always
locally seems like a good
idea to eat another cookie,
but maybe it'll bite
you in the future.
So today we will embrace
our inner Cookie Monster
and eat as many-- eat
the largest cookie first,
would be the standard
algorithm for Cookie Monster.
I don't know if you learned
that in Sesame Street,
but-- all right.
So what's the problem?
Minimum spanning tree.
Can anyone tell
me what a tree is?
Formally, not the outside thing.
In graph land.
Acyclic graph, close.
Connected acyclic graph, good.
That's important.
This is 604.2 stuff.
OK, so how about
a spanning tree?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: It contains
all the vertices.
ERIK DEMAINE: It contains
Yeah.
So let me go over here.
Spanning means it contains all
the vertices, so implicit here,
I guess, is subtree or subgraph.
You're given a graph.
You want a spanning
tree of that graph.
It's going to be a tree
that lives inside the graph.
So we're going to take
some of the edges of G,
make a tree out of them, make
a connected acyclic graph.
And that tree should hit
all the vertices in G.
So this is going to be a subset
of the edges, or subgraph.
Those edges should form a tree.
And, I'll say, hit
all vertices of G.
OK, if I just said they
should form a tree,
then I could say, well,
I'll take no edges,
and here's a tree
with one vertex.
That's not very interesting.
You want a vertex--
you want, basically,
the vertex set of the tree
to be the same as the vertex
set of the graph.
That's the spanning property.
But you still want
it to be a tree,
so you want it to be connected
and you want it to be acyclic.
Now if G is disconnected,
this is impossible.
And for that, you could
define a spanning forest
to be like a maximal
thing like this,
but we'll focus on the case
here as G is connected.
That's the interesting case.
And so we can get
a spanning tree.
All right?
So what is this minimum
spanning tree problem?
Minimum spanning tree.
We're given a weighted
graph, just like last time,
with shortest paths.
We have an edge weight function
W giving me a real number, say,
for every edge.
And we want to find a spanning
tree of minimum total weight.
So I'm going to define
the weight of a tree T
to be the sum over
all edges in T,
because I'm viewing a spanning
tree as a set of edges,
of the weight of that edge.
OK, so pretty much
what you would expect.
Minimum weight spanning tree.
It's a relatively
simple problem,
but it's not so easy
to find an algorithm.
You need to prove a lot to
make sure that you really
find the right tree.
I guess the really
naive algorithm here
would be to try
all spanning trees,
compute the weight
of each spanning tree
and return the minimum.
That sounds reasonable.
That's correct.
But it's bad, because-- n to
the fourth, that would be nice.
It's larger than that.
Maybe not so obvious, but
it can be exponential.
Here's a graph where the
number of spanning trees
is exponential.
This is a complete
bipartite graph
with two vertices on one side
and n vertices on the other,
and so you can-- let's
say we put these two
edges into the spanning tree.
And now, for each
of these vertices,
we can choose whether it
connects to the left vertex
or the right vertix.
It can only do one, but it could
do either one independently.
So maybe this guy
chooses the left one,
this one chooses the right one.
This one chooses the
left one, and so on.
If I have n vertices down here,
I have 2 to the n different
spanning trees.
So there can be an
exponential number.
So that algorithm
is not so good.
Exponential bad.
Polynomial good.
So today, we're going to
get a polynomial algorithm.
In fact, we will get an almost
linear time algorithm as fast
as Dijkstra's algorithm.
But we can't use
Dijkstra's algorithm,
there's no shortest paths here.
Plus, one of the algorithms will
actually look pretty similar.
Two lectures ago, the
dynamic programming lecture,
we saw an example where
we tried to do greedy,
and it gave the
wrong answer, and so
we fell back on
dynamic programming.
Today, we're going to try
to do dynamic programming,
it's going to fail, and we're
going to fall back on greedy.
It's like the reverse.
But the way it's
going to fail is
we're going to get
exponential time initially,
and then greedy will let
us get polynomial time.
This is actually a bit unusual.
I would say more typically,
dynamic programming
can solve anything,
but, you know, with n
to the seventh running
time, something slow.
And then you apply
greedy, and you get down
to like n or n log
n running time.
So that's more common.
But today, we're going
to go from exponential
down to polynomial.
And that's pretty nice.
Cool.
So let me tell you a little
bit about greedy algorithm
theory, so to speak.
This is from the textbook.
If your problem can be
solved by greedy algorithm,
usually you can
prove two properties
about that algorithm.
One of them is called
optimal substructure.
And the other is called
the greedy choice property.
Optimal substructure
should be familiar idea
because it's essentially
an encapsulation
of dynamic programming.
Greedy algorithms
are, in some sense,
a special form of
dynamic programming.
So this is saying
something like,
if you can solve
subproblems optimally,
smaller subproblems, or
whatever, then you can
solve your original problem.
And this may happen
recursively, whatever.
That's essentially
what makes a recurrence
work for dynamic programming.
And with dynamic programming,
for this to be possible,
we need to guess some
feature of the solution.
For example, in
minimum spanning tree,
maybe you guess one of the edges
that's in the right answer.
And then, once you do
that, you can reduce it
to some other subproblems.
And if you can solve
those subproblems,
you combine them and
get an optimal solution
to your original thing.
So this is a familiar property.
I don't usually think of it this
way for dynamic programming,
but that is essentially what
we're doing via guessing.
But with greedy algorithms,
we're not going to guess.
We're just going to be greedy.
Eat the largest cookie.
And so that's the
greedy choice property.
This says that eating
the largest cookie
is actually a good thing to do.
If we keep making
locally optimal choices,
will end up with a
globally optimal solution.
No tummy ache.
This is something you wouldn't
expect to be true in general,
but it's going to be true
for minimum spanning tree.
And it's true for a
handful of other problems.
You'll see a bunch more
in recitation tomorrow.
This is sort of general
theory, but I'm actually
going to have a theorem like
this for minimum spanning tree
and a theorem like this
for minimum spanning tree.
This is the prototype, but most
of today is all about minimum
spanning tree.
And for minimum spanning
tree, neither of these
is very obvious.
So I'm just going to
show you these theorems.
They're fairly easy to prove,
in fact, but finding them
is probably the tricky part.
Actually, I guess optimal
substructure is probably
the least intuitive or the
least obvious greedy choice.
You're probably
already thinking,
what are good greedy choices?
Minimum weight edge seems
like a good starting point,
which we will get to.
But there's even
a stronger version
of that, which we will prove.
And first, optimal substructure.
So here, I'm going to think
like a dynamic program.
Let's suppose that we know an
edge that's in our solution.
Suppose we know
an edge that lives
in a minimum spanning tree.
We could guess that.
We're not going
to, but we could.
Either way, let's just
suppose than an edge e--
I should mention, I
guess I didn't say,
this graph is undirected.
A minimum spanning tree
doesn't quite make sense
with directed graphs.
There are other
versions of the problem
but here, the graph
is undirected.
So probably, I should write
this as a unordered set, u,
v. And there are possibly
many minimum spanning trees.
There could be many solutions
with the same weight.
For example, if all of
these edges have weight 1,
all of these trees
are actually minimum.
If all the edges have weight
1, every spanning tree
is minimum, because every
spanning tree has exactly
n minus 1 edges.
But let's suppose we
know an edge that's
guaranteed to be in some minimum
spanning tree, at least one.
What I would like to do is take
this, so let me draw a picture.
I have a graph.
We've identified some edge
in the graph, e, that lives
in some minimum spanning tree.
I'm going to draw some kind
of tree structure here.
OK.
The wiggly lines are the tree.
There are some
other edges in here,
which I don't want to draw too
many of them because it's ugly.
Those are other
edges in the graph.
Who knows where they are?
They could be all
sorts of things.
OK?
But I've highlighted the
graph in a particular way.
Because the minimum
spanning tree
is a tree, if I delete
e from the tree, then
I get two components.
Every edge I remove--
I'm minimally connected.
So if I delete an edge, I
disconnect into two parts,
so I've drawn that as the left
circle and the right circle.
It's just a general way
to think about a tree.
Now there are other unused
edges in this picture,
who knows where they live?
OK?
What I would like to do is
somehow simplify this graph
and get a smaller problem,
say a graph with fewer edges.
Any suggestions
on how to do that?
I don't actually know where
all these white edges are,
but what I'd like to do is--
I'm supposing I know where e is,
and that's an edge in my
minimum spanning tree.
So how could I get rid of it?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Find
the minimum weight
spanning tree of the two edges.
ERIK DEMAINE: I'd like
to divide and conquer.
Maybe find the
minimum weight over
here, minimum weight over here.
Of course, I don't know
which nodes are in what side.
So that's a little trickier.
But what do I do but E itself?
Let's start with that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You remove it?
ERIK DEMAINE: You
could remove it.
That's a good idea.
Doesn't work, but worth
a Frisbee nonetheless.
If I delete this
edge, one problem
is maybe none of these red
edges exist and then my graph
is disconnected.
Well, maybe that's
actually a good case.
That probably would
be a good case.
Then I know how to
divide and conquer.
I just look at the
connected components.
In general, if I
delete the edge,
and I have these red
edges, then I maybe
find a minimum spanning
tree on what remains.
Maybe I'll end up including
one of these edges.
Maybe this edge ends up
in the spanning tree,
and then I can't put E in.
So it's a little awkward.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you merge
the two nodes into one?
Merge the two nodes into one.
Yes.
Purple Frisbee.
Impressive.
This is what we call
contracting the edge.
It just means merge
the endpoints.
Merge u and v. So I will draw
a new version of the graph.
So this was u and v before.
You've got to put
the label inside.
And now we have a new
vertex here, which is uv.
Or you can think it
as the set u, v. We
won't really need to
keep track of names.
And whatever edges
you had over here,
you're going to have over here.
OK?
Just collapse u and v.
The edge e disappears.
And one other thing can happen.
Let me-- go over here.
We could end up with duplicate
edges by this process.
So for example, suppose
we have u and v,
and they have a common neighbor.
Might have many common
neighbors, who knows.
Add some other edges,
uncommon neighbors.
When I merge, I'd
like to just have
a single edge to that vertex and
a single edge to that vertex.
And what I'm going
to do is, if I
have some weights on these
edges, let's say a and b,
and c and d, I'm just
going to take the minimum.
Because what I'm about to do is
compute a minimum spanning tree
in this graph.
And if I take the minimum
spanning tree here,
and I had multiple
edges-- one weight a,
one weight b-- do you think I
would choose the larger weight
edge?
It does-- they're
exactly the same edge,
but one is higher weight.
There's no point in keeping
the higher weight one,
so I'm just going to throw
away the higher weight one.
Take them in.
So this is a particular form
of edge contraction and graphs.
And I claim it's a good
thing to do, in the sense
that if I can find a
minimum spanning tree
in this new graph--
this is usually
called a G slash e, slash
instead of negative, to remove
e.
I'm contracting e.
So this is G slash e.
This is G. If I can find a
minimum spanning tree in G
slash e, I claim I can find
one in the original graph G
just by adding the edge e.
So I'm going to
say if G prime is
a minimum spanning
tree, of G slash e,
then T prime union e is a
minimum spanning tree of G.
So overall, you
can think of this
as a recurrence in
a dynamic program,
and let me write down
that dynamic program.
It won't be very
good dynamic program,
but it's a starting point.
This is conceptually
what we want to do.
We're trying to guess
an edge e that's
in a minimum spanning tree.
Then we're going to
contract that edge.
Then we're going to recurse,
find the minimum spanning tree
on what remains, and then we
find the minimum spanning tree.
Then we want to
decontract the edge,
put it back, put the
graph back the way it was.
And then add e to the
minimum spanning tree.
And what this lemma
tells us, is that this
is a correct algorithm.
If you're lucky-- and we're
going to force luckiness
by trying all edges-- but if
we start with an edge that
is guaranteed to be in some
minimum spanning tree, call it
a safe edge, and
we contract, and we
find a minimum spanning
tree on what remains,
then we can put e
back in at the end,
and we'll get a minimum spanning
tree of the original graph.
So this gives us correctness
of this algorithm.
Now, this algorithm's
bad, again,
from a complexity standpoint.
The running time is
going to be exponential.
The number of sub problems we
might have to consider here
is all subsets of edges.
There's no particular way--
because at every step,
we're guessing an arbitrary
edge in the graph,
there's no structure.
Like, we can't say well,
it's the first k edges,
or some substring of edges.
It's just going to be
some subset of edges.
There's exponentially
many subsets, 2 to the e,
so this is exponential.
But we're going to
make a polynomial
by removing the guessing.
This is actually a
really good prototype
for a greedy algorithm.
If instead of guessing,
trying all edges,
if we could find a
good edge to choose
that's guaranteed to be in
a minimum spanning tree,
then we could actually
follow this procedure,
and this would be like
an iterative algorithm.
If you-- you don't
guess-- you correctly
choose a good-- you
take the biggest cookie,
you contract it, and then
you repeat that process
over and over, that
would be a prototype
for a greedy algorithm and
that's what's going to work.
There's different ways to
choose this greedy edge,
and we're going to get
two different algorithms
accordingly.
But that's where we're going.
First, I should prove
this claim, cause,
you know, where did edge
contraction come from?
Why does it work?
It's not too hard to prove.
Let's do it.
Question?
Oh.
All right.
I should be able to do
this without looking.
So--
Proof of optimal substructure.
So we're given a lot.
We're told that e belongs
to a minimize spanning tree.
Let's give that
spanning tree a name.
Say we have a minimum spanning
tree T star, which contains e.
So we're assuming that
exists, then we contract e.
And then we're
given T prime, which
is a minimum spanning
tree of G slash e.
And then we want to
analyze this thing.
So I want to claim
that this thing is
a minimum spanning
tree, in other words,
that the weight of
that spanning tree
is equal to the weight
of this spanning tree,
because this one is minimum.
This is a minimum spanning
of G. And this is also
supposed to be a minimum
spanning tree of G.
OK.
Sounds easy, right?
I'm going to cheat, sorry.
I see.
Right.
Duh.
Easy, once you know how.
So what we're going to do is
think about contracting e.
OK, we already
know we're supposed
to be thinking about
contracting e in the graph.
Let's look at how it changes
that given minimum spanning
tree.
So we have T star,
minimum spanning
tree of the whole graph, and
then I'm going to contract e.
What I mean is, if
that edge happens
to be in the spanning
tree-- it is, actually.
We assumed that e is in there.
So I'm basically removing,
I'm just deleting that edge,
maybe I should call it minus e.
Then that should be a
spanning tree of G slash e.
So when I contract
the edge in the graph,
if I throw away the edge
from this spanning tree,
I should still have
a spanning tree,
and I don't know
whether it's minimum.
Probably, it is, but we
won't prove that right now.
I claim it's still
a spanning tree.
What would that take?
It still hits all the vertices,
because if I removed the edge,
things would not be
connected together.
But this edge was in
the spanning tree,
and then I fused those
two vertices together,
so whatever spanning-- I
mean, whatever was connected
before is still connected.
Contraction generally
preserves connectivity.
If these things were already
connected directly by an edge
when I contract, I still
have a connected structure,
so I'm still hitting
all the vertices.
And also, the number of
edges is still exactly right.
Before, I had n minus 1 edges.
Afterwards, I'll still
have n minus 1 edges,
because I removed one edge
and I removed one vertex,
in terms of the count.
So that proves that it's
still a spanning tree,
using properties of trees.
Cool.
So that means the minimum
spanning tree, this thing,
T prime, the minimum
spanning tree of G slash e,
has a smaller weight
than this one.
Because this is a
spanning tree, the minimum
is smaller than
all spanning trees.
So we know the
weight of T prime is
less than or equal to the
weight of T star minus e.
Cool.
And now we want to know about
this thing, the weight of T
prime plus e.
Well, that's just the weight of
T prime plus the weight of e,
because the weight
of a tree is just
the sum of the
weights of the edges.
So this is less
than or equal to w
of T star minus e plus e, which
is just the weight of T star.
So we proved that the weight
of our proposed spanning tree
is less than or equal to
the weight of the minimum
spanning tree in G, and
therefore, T prime union
e actually is a
minimum spanning tree.
OK?
This is really easy.
It actually implies that
all of these inequalities
have to be
equalities, because we
started with something minimum.
Clear?
That's the easier half.
The
More interesting property is
going to be this greedy choice
property.
This is sort of where the
action is for greedy algorithms,
and this is usually
the heart of proving
greedy algorithms are correct.
We don't yet have
a greedy algorithm,
but we're thinking about it.
We need some way to
intelligently choose an edge e,
and I'm going to give
you a whole bunch of ways
to intelligently
choose an edge e.
So here's a really
powerful lemma,
and we're going to make it
even stronger in a moment.
So I'm going to introduce
the notion of a cut, that's
going to be a similar
picture to what I had before.
I'm going to look at
some set of vertices.
S here is a subset
of the vertices,
and that leaves in the
graph, everything else.
This would be V minus
S. OK, so there's
some vertices over here,
there's some edges
that are purely
inside one side of the cut.
And then what I'm
interested in are
the edges that cross the cut.
OK, whatever they look
like, these edges.
If an edge has one vertex in
V and one vertex not in V,
I call that edge
a crossing edge.
OK, so let's suppose that e is
a least-weight edge crossing
the cut.
So let's say, let me be
specific, if e is uv,
then I want one of the
endpoints, let's u, to be in S,
and I want the other
one to be not in S,
so it's in capital
V minus S. And that
would be a crossing edge, and
among all the crossing edges,
I want to take one
of minimum weight.
There might be many,
but pick any one.
Then I claim that edge is
in a minimum spanning tree.
This is our golden
ticket, right?
If we can guarantee an edge is
in the minimum spanning tree,
then we plug that in here.
Instead of guessing, we'll
just take that edge--
we know it's in a
minimum spanning tree--
and then we'll contract it
and repeat this process.
So the tricky part-- I mean, it
is true that the minimum weight
edge is in a minimum spanning
tree, I'll give that away.
But the question is,
what you do then?
And I guess you
contract and repeat
but, that will be
Kruskal's algorithm.
But this is, in some
sense, a more general tool
that will let us identify
edges that are guaranteed
to be in the minimum
spanning tree,
even after we've already
identified some edges as being
in the minimum spanning tree,
so it's a little more powerful.
Let's prove this claim.
This is where things
get particularly cool.
And this is where we're
going to use something
called a c and paste argument.
And if you are ever
trying to prove
a greedy algorithm
correct, the first thing
that should come to your
mind is cut and paste.
This is almost universally how
you prove greedy algorithms
to be correct, which is, suppose
you have some optimal solution
which doesn't have
the property you want,
like that it includes e here.
And then you modify it,
usually by cutting out
one part of the solution and
pasting in a different part,
like e, and prove that you
still have an optimal solution,
and therefore, there
is an optimal solution.
There is an MST that has
the property you want.
OK, so we're going to do that
by starting from an arbitrary
minimum spanning tree.
So let T star be a minimum
spanning tree of G,
and if the edge e is
in there, we're done.
So presumably, e is not in
that minimum spanning tree.
We're going to modify
T star to include e.
So again, let me draw the cut.
There's S and V minus
S. We have some edge e
which crosses the
cut, goes from u to v,
that's not in the
minimum spanning tree.
Let's say in blue, I draw
the minimum spanning tree.
So you know, the
minimum spanning tree
connects everything
together here.
I claim it's got to have some
edges that cross the cut,
because if it has no
it doesn't connect vertices over
here with vertices over here.
So it may not use e, but some
of the edges must cross the cut.
So here's a possible
minimum spanning tree.
It happens to have sort of
two components over here
in S, maybe.
Who knows?
But there's got to be at least
one edge the crosses over.
In fact, the minimum
spanning tree, T star,
has to connect vertex
u to vertex v, somehow.
It doesn't use e, but there's
got to be-- it's a tree,
so in fact, there has to
be a unique path from u
to v in the minimum
spanning tree.
And now u is in S, v is not in
S. So if you look at that path,
for a while, you
might stay in S,
but eventually you
have to leave S, which
means there has to be an
edge like this one, which
I'll call it e prime,
which transitions
from S to V minus S.
So there must be an edge e prime
in the minimum spanning tree
that crosses the cut, because
u and v are connected by a path
and that path starts in S,
ends not in S, so it's got
to transition at least once.
It might transition many
times, but there has
to be at least one such edge.
And now what I'm going
to do is cut and paste.
I'm going to remove e
prime and add an e instead.
So I'm going to look at T
star minus e prime plus e.
I claim that is a
minimum spanning tree.
First I want to claim, this is
maybe the more annoying part,
that it is a spanning tree.
This is more of a
graph theory thing.
I guess one comforting
thing is that you've
preserved the number of
edges, so it should still
be if you get one
property, you get
the other, because I remove
one edge, add in one edge,
I'm still going to
have n minus 1 edges.
The worry, I guess, is that
things become disconnected
when you do that, but
that's essentially not
going to happen
because if I think
of removing e prime, again, that
disconnects the tree into two
parts.
And I know, by this path, that
one part contains this vertex,
another part
contains this vertex,
and I know that this
vertex is connected to u
and this vertex is connected
to v. Maybe I should
call this u prime and v prime.
I know u and u prime
are connected by a path.
I know v and v prime
But I know that by
deleting e prime,
u prime and v prime are not
connected to each other.
Therefore, u and v are not
connected to each other,
after removing e prime.
So when I add in e, I newly
connect u and v again,
and so everything's
connected back together.
I have exactly the
right number of edges.
Therefore, I'm a spanning tree.
So that's the graph
three theory part.
Now the interesting part
from a greedy algorithm
is to prove to this is minimum,
that the weight is not too big.
So let's do that over here.
So I have the weight of T
star minus e plus-- minus e
prime plus e.
By linearity, this
is just the weight
of T star minus the weight e
prime plus the weight of e.
And now we're going
to use this property,
we haven't that yet, e is a
least-weight edge crossing
the cut.
So e prime crosses
the cut, so does e,
but e is the smallest
possible weight you
could have crossing the cut.
That means that-- I'll put that
over here-- the weight of e
is less than or equal
to the weight of e
prime, because e prime is
a particular edge crossing
the cut, e was the
smallest weight of them.
So that tells us
something about this.
Signs are so difficult.
I think that means
that this is negative or zero.
So this should be less than
or equal to w of T star,
and that's what I
want, because that
says the weight of this
spanning tree is less than
or equal to the optimum
weight, the minimum weight.
So that means, actually,
this must be minimum.
So what I've done is I've
constructed a new minimum
spanning tree.
It's just as good as T star,
but now it includes my edge e,
and that's what I
wanted to prove.
There is a minimum
spanning tree that
contains e, provided e
is the minimum weight
edge crossing a cut.
So that proves this
greedy choice property.
And I'm going to observe one
extra feature of this proof,
which is that-- so
we cut and paste,
in the sense that we removed
one thing, which was e prime,
and we added a
different thing, e.
And a useful feature is that
the things that we change only
are edges that cross the cut.
So we only, let's say, modified
edges that cross the cut.
I'm going to use that later.
We removed one edge that crossed
the cut, and we put in the one
that we wanted.
OK so far?
There's a bunch of lemmas.
Now we actually get to do
algorithms using these lemmas.
We'll start with maybe the
less obvious algorithm,
but it's nice because it's
very much like Dijkstra.
It follows very closely
to the Dijkstra model.
And then we'll get to
the one that we've all
been thinking about, which
was choose a minimum weight
edge, contract, and repeat.
That doesn't-- well, that does
work, but the obvious way is,
maybe, slow.
We want to do it in
near linear time.
Let's start with the
Dijkstra-like algorithm.
This is Prim's algorithm.
Maybe I'll start by
writing down the algorithm.
It's a little long.
In general, the idea-- we want
to apply this greedy choice
property.
To apply the greedy
choice property,
you need to choose a cut.
With Prim, we're going to start
out with an obvious cut, which
is a single vertex.
If we have a single
vertex S, and we
say that is our set
capital S, then you know,
there's some images
coming out of it.
There's basically S
versus everyone else.
That's a cut.
And so I could take
the minimum weight edge
coming out of that
cut and put that
in my minimum spanning tree.
So when I do that, I put it
in my minimum spanning tree
because I know it's in
some minimum spanning tree.
Now, I'm going to make capital
S grow a little bit to include
that vertex, and repeat.
That's actually also a
very natural algorithm.
Start with a tiny s and just
keep growing it one by one.
At each stage use this lemma to
guarantee the edge I'm adding
is still in the
minimum spanning tree.
So to make that work
out, we're always
going to need to choose the
minimum weight edge that's
coming out of the cut.
And we'll do that
using a priority queue,
just like we do in Dijkstra.
So for every vertex
that's in V minus S,
we're going to have that
vertex in the priority queue.
And the question is, what is
the key value of that node
stored in the priority queue?
So the invariant I'm going
to have is that the key of v
is the minimum of the
weights of the edges
that cross the cut into
v. So for vertex v,
I want to look at
the-- I'm not going
to compute this every time,
I'm only going to maintain it.
I want the minimum weight
of an edge that starts in S
and goes to v, which is not in
S because v in Q-- Q only stores
vertices that are not in
S-- I want the key value
to be that minimum
weight so if I choose
the overall minimum
vertex, that gives me
the edge of minimum weight
that crosses the cut.
OK?
I've sort of divided this
minimum vertex by vertex.
For every vertex
over here, I'm going
to say, what's the minimum
incoming weight from somebody
over here?
What's the minimum
incoming weight
from someone over here to there?
To here?
Take the minimum
of those things.
And of course, the
min of all those
will be the min of
all those edges.
OK, that's how I'm
dividing things up.
And this will be easier
to maintain, but let me
first initialize everything.
OK, I guess we're going
to actually initialize
with S being the empty set,
so Q will store everybody,
except I'm going to get
things started by setting
for particular vertex little s.
I'm going to set
its key to zero.
It doesn't matter
who little s is.
That's just your start vertex.
Just pick one vertex
and set its key to zero.
That will force it
to be chosen first
because for everyone else,
for v not equal to S,
I'm going to set
the key to infinity,
because we haven't yet seen
any edges that go in there,
but we'll change
that in a moment.
OK, so that was the
initialization, now
we're going to do a loop.
We're going to keep going
until the Q is empty,
because when the Q is empty,
that means S is everybody,
and at that point, we'll
have a spanning tree
on the whole graph, and
it better be minimum.
OK, and we're going to
do that by extracting
the minimum from
our priority Q. When
we remove Q-- we remove
vertex u from the queue Q,
this means that we're
adding u to S. OK,
by taking it out of Q,
that means it enters S,
by the invariant at the top.
So now we need to
update this invariant,
that all the key
values are correct.
As soon as we move
a vertex into S,
now there are new edges we have
to consider from S to not S,
and we do that just by looking
at all of the neighbors of u.
I haven't written
this in a long time,
but this is how it's
usually written in Dijkstra,
except in Dijkstra, these
are the outgoing edges from u
and v are the neighbors.
Here, it's an undirected
graph, so these are
all of the neighbors v of u.
This as an adjacency list.
OK, so we're looking at u,
which has just been added to S,
and we're looking at the edges.
We want to look at the edge
as they go to V minus S, only
those ones.
And then for those vertices v,
we need to update their keys,
because it used to just
count all of these edges that
went from the rest of S to
v. And now we have a new edge
uv that v needs to consider,
because u just got added to S.
So the first thing I'm
going say is if v in in Q.
So we're just going to store
a Boolean for every vertex
about whether it's
in the queue, and so
when I extract it
from the queue,
I just set that
Boolean to false.
Being in the queue is the
same as being not in S,
this is what Q represents.
So Q is over here, kind of.
So if we're in the queue,
same as saying v is not in S,
then we're going
to do a check which
lets us compute the minimum.
This is going to look a
lot like a relaxation.
Sorry.
A couple things
going on because I
want to compute
not just the value
of the minimum spanning
tree, I actually
want to find the
minimum spanning tree,
so I'm going to store
parent pointers.
But this is just
basically taking a min.
I say, if the
weight of this edge
is smaller than what's
currently in the key,
then update the key, because the
key is supposed to be the min.
OK, that's all we need to do to
maintain this invariant, this
for loop.
After the for loop, this
property will be restored,
v dot key will be that minimum.
And furthermore, we kept track
of where the minimums came
from, so when you end
up extracting a vertex,
you've already figured
out which edge you
added to put that into the set.
So in fact, u
already had a parent,
this would be u
dot parent, and we
want to add that edge into
the minimum spanning tree
when we add u to S. Overall, let
me write why this is happening.
At the end of the algorithm,
for every vertex v,
we want the v dot parent.
And that will be our
minimum spanning tree.
Those are the edges that form
the minimum spanning tree.
Let's prove that this works.
Actually, let's do an example.
We've done enough
proofs for a while.
Let's do it over here.
I need a little break.
Examples are fun, though easy
to make mistakes, so correct me
if you see me making a mistake.
And let me draw a graph.
OK, weights.
14, 3, 8, 5, 6, 12, 7, 9, 15.
10.
OK.
Colors.
So I want to start
at this vertex
just because I know it
does an interesting thing,
or it's a nice example.
Here's my weighted
undirected graph.
I want to compute
minimum spanning tree.
I'm going to start
with a capital
S being-- well actually, I start
with capital S being nothing,
and all of the weights--
all of the key values
are initially infinity.
So I'm going to write
the key values in blue.
So initially everything is
infinity for every vertex,
except for S the value is zero.
So all of these things
are in my priority queue,
and so when I extract from the
queue, I of course get S. OK,
that's the point of that set up.
So that's when I draw the red
circle containing little s.
The red circle here is
supposed to be capital S.
So at this point, I've
added capital S-- little s
to capital S, and then I look
at all of the neighbors v of S.
And I make sure that they are
outside of S. In this case,
they all are.
All three neighbors, these
three guys, are not in S.
And then I look at the
weights of the edges.
Here I have a weight 7 edge.
That's smaller than
infinity, so I'm
going to cross out
infinity and write 7.
And 15 is smaller
than infinity, so I'm
going to cross out
infinity and write 15.
And 10, surprise, is
smaller than infinity.
So I'm going to cross
out infinity rate 10.
So now I've updated the key
values for those three nodes.
I should mention in
the priority queue,
to do that, that is a
decrease-key operation.
This thing here
is a decrease-key.
You need to update the
priority queue to say,
hey look, the key of
this node changed.
And so you're going to have
to move it around in the heap,
or whatever.
Just like Dijkstra,
same thing happens.
OK, so I've decreased the
key of those three nodes.
Now I do another iteration.
I look at all of the
key values stored.
The smallest one is 7, because
this node's no longer in there.
So I'm going to add
this node to capital S.
So capital S is going to
grow to include that node.
I've extracted it
from the queue.
And now I look at all the
neighbors of that node.
So, for example,
here's a neighbor.
9 is less than
infinity, so I write 9.
Here's a neighbor.
12 is less than
infinity, so I write 12.
5 is less than
infinity, so I write 5.
Here's a neighbor,
but s is in big S,
so we're not going
to touch that edge.
I'm not going to touch s.
OK?
I will end up looking at every
edge twice, so no big deal.
Right now, who's smallest?
5, I think.
It's the smallest blue key.
So we're going to
add 5 to the set.
Sorry, add this
vertex to the set S,
and then look at all of the
outgoing edges from here.
So 6 is actually less
than 12, so this edge
is better than that one was.
Then, what's that, an 8?
8 Is less than 10.
14 is definitely
less than infinity.
And we look at this
edge, but that edge
stays inside the red set,
so we forget about it.
Next smallest value is 6.
So 6, we add this guy in.
We look at the edges
from that vertex,
but actually nothing happens
because all those vertices
are inside capital S, so we
don't care about those edges.
Next one is 8, so we'll
add in this vertex.
And there's only one edge that
leaves the cut, so that's 3,
and 3 is indeed better than 14.
So never mind.
Stop.
So good, now I think
the smallest key is 3.
Notice smallest key is
smaller than anything
we've seen before, other
than 0, but that's OK.
I'll just add it in,
and there's no edges
leaving the cut from there.
And then over here,
we have 9 and 15.
So first we'll add 9.
There's no edges there.
Then we add 15.
OK, now s is everything.
We're done.
Q is empty.
Where's the minimal
spanning tree?
I forgot to draw it.
Luckily, all of the edges
here have different numbers
as labels.
So when I have a 3
here, what I mean is,
include 3 in the
minimum spanning tree,
the edge that was labeled 3.
OK, so this will be a
minimum spanning tree edge.
5 will be a minimum
spanning tree edge.
These are actually
the parent pointers.
6 will be a minimum
spanning tree edge.
7, 9, 15, and 8.
Every vertex except
the starting one
will have a parent, which means
we'll have exactly n minus 1
edges, that's a good sign.
And in fact, this will be
a minimum spanning tree.
That's the claim, because
every time we grew the circle
to include a bigger
thing, we were
guaranteed that this edge was
in the minimum spanning tree
by applying this
property with that cut.
Let me just write that down.
OK, to prove
correctness, you need
to prove an invariant that this
key, the key of every vertex,
always remains this minimum.
So this is an invariant.
You should prove
that by induction.
I won't prove it here.
But we have another invariant,
a more interesting one
from an MST
perspective, you know,
it's just a sort of algorithm
implementation detail,
that the tree T sub S,
within S is always contained
in a minimum spanning
tree of G. So over here,
we have this way of computing
minimum spanning tree
for all vertices v,
but what I'd like
to do is just look
at v that's currently
in S. By the end, that
will be the whole thing,
but if I look at v in S, and I
always look at the edge from v
to v dot parent, that
gives me this tree TS.
I claim it will be contained
in a minimum spanning tree
of the entire graph,
proof by induction.
So by induction, let's assume--
induction hypothesis will
be that, let's say there is
a minimum spanning tree T
star, which contains
T sub S, and then what
the algorithm does, is it
repeatedly grows S by adding
this vertex u to S. So let's
suppose that it adds u to S.
So I'm actually going to look
at the edge that it adds.
So we have S and V minus S, and
we do this thing, like we just
saw, of growing by one.
We add one new vertex
over here to S,
and that vertex has a parent
edge, has a parent pointer.
So this edge, I'm
going to call e.
So we're adding some vertex u
that we extract at the minimum,
and we also added an
edge e to this TS,
because we grew S by 1.
OK, when I do that,
all I do is say, look,
greedy choice
property guarantees
there's a minimum spanning
tree that contains e.
Because we extracted
the min from the queue,
and the key values are this,
as I was arguing before,
that is the minimum overall
edge that crosses the cut.
e is a minimum weight
edge that crosses the cut,
and so by greedy
choice property,
there is some minimum
spanning tree that contains e.
But actually, I need that
the minimum spanning tree
not only contains e, but also
contains all the other spanning
tree edges that we had
already said were in T star.
OK, so here's where I'm going
to use the stronger property.
I can modify T star to
include e and T sub S.
So we already assumed that T
star includes T sub S. I just
don't want to break that.
And if you remember the proof
of this greedy choice property,
we said, well all we need to do
is remove one edge that crosses
the cut and replace it with e.
So here what I'm saying
is there's some edge,
yeah, maybe there's some
edge over here in T star
that we had to remove,
and then we put e in.
And then we get a minimum
spanning tree again,
T star prime.
OK, this edge that I remove
cannot be one of the TS edges
because the TS edges
are all inside S.
So because I'm only removing
an edge that crosses the cut,
I'm not disturbing TS.
TS will remain inside T star,
but then I get the new property
that e is inside T star, and so
I prove this invariant holds.
OK?
I keep changing T star, but I
always preserve the property
that all of the spanning
tree edges that are inside S
are contained in some minimum
spanning tree of G. Maybe
I'll add in some for emphasis.
Cool?
So that's how we use
the greedy choice
property to get correctness
of Prim's algorithm.
What's the running time
of Prim's algorithm?
Same as Dijkstra, good answer.
I guess it depends what
priority queue you use,
but whatever priority queue you
use, it's the same as Dijkstra.
And so in particular, if we
use Fibonacci heaps, which,
again, we're not covering, we
get V log V plus E. In general,
for every edge, we have
to do a decrease-key.
Actually, for every edge we do
two decrease-key operations,
potentially, if
you think about it.
But this for loop over
the adjacency, the cost
of this stuff is constant.
The cost of this is the
degree of the vertex u.
And so we're basically
doing the sum
of the degrees of
the vertices, which
is the number of edges times 2.
That's the handshaking lemma.
So for every edge,
we're potentially
doing one decrease-key
operation,
and with Fibonacci heaps,
that's constant time.
But we're also doing V extract
mins those cost log V time,
cause the size of
the queue is at most
V, and so that is actually
the right running time.
Just like Dijkstra, so
easy formula to remember.
All right, let's do one more
algorithm, Kruskal's algorithm.
Kruskal's algorithm is a
little bit weirder from the S
perspective, I guess.
We'll see what cuts
we're using in a moment,
but it's based
around this idea of,
well, the globally
minimum weight
edge is the minimum weight edge
for all cuts that cross it,
or for all cuts that it crosses.
The globally minimum weight edge
is going to be a valid choice,
and so, by this
theorem, you pick
some S that partitions
the endpoints of e,
therefore e is in a
minimum spanning tree.
So let's choose that one
first, and then repeat.
Conceptually, what we want to
do is that DP idea of contract
the vertex, sorry,
contract the edge
and then find the minimum
weight edge that remains.
But the way I'm going to phrase
it doesn't explicitly contract,
although implicitly,
it's doing that.
And there's a catch.
The catch is suppose I've
picked some edges out to be
in my minimum spanning tree.
Suppose this was
the minimum weight
and this was the next minimum,
next minimum, next minimum,
next minimum.
Suppose that the next
lar-- at this point,
after contracting those
edges, the minimum weight edge
is this one.
Do I want to put this edge
in my minimum spanning tree?
No.
That would add a cycle.
Cycles are bad.
This is the tricky
part of this algorithm.
I have to keep track of
whether I should actually
add an edge, in other
words, whether this vertex
and this vertex have already
been connected to each other.
And it turns out you've
already seen a data structure
to do that.
This is what I call
union-find and the textbook
calls it disjoint-set
data structure.
So it's in recitation.
Recitation 3.
So I want to maintain
for my MST so far,
so I'm adding edges
one at a time.
And I have some tree-- well,
it's actually a forest,
but I'm still
going to call it T,
and I'm going to maintain it
in a union-find structure,
disjoint-set set data structure.
Remember, this had three
operations, make set, union,
and find set.
Tell me given an item which
set does it belong to?
We're going to use
that, the sets are going
to be the connected components.
So after I've added these edges,
these guys, these vertices
here, will form one
connected component,
and, you know,
everybody else will just
be in its own
separate component.
So to get started, I'm not going
to have any edges in my tree,
and so every vertex is in
its own connected component.
So I represent that by calling
make-set v for all vertices.
So every vertex lives in
its own singleton set.
OK, now I'd like to do the
minimum weight edge, and then
the next minimum weight edge,
and the next minimum weight
edge.
That's also known
as sorting, so I'm
going to sort E by
weight, increasing weight,
so I get to start with
the minimum weight edge.
So now I'm going to do a
for-loop over the edges,
increasing order by weight.
Now I want to know--
I have an edge,
it's basically the minimum
weight edge among the edges
that remain, and so I want to
know whether I should add it.
I'm going to add it provided
the endpoints of the edge
are not in the same
connected component.
How can I find out
whether two vertices
are in the same connected
component, given this setup?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Call find-set
twice and then--
ERIK DEMAINE: Call
find-set twice and see
whether they're equal, exactly.
Good answer.
So if you find-set of u
is from find-set of v,
find-set just returns
some identifier.
We don't really care
what it is, as long
as it returns the same
thing for the same set.
So if u and v are in the
same set, in other words,
they're in the same
connected component,
then find-set will return
the same thing for both.
But provided they're
not equal, then
we can add this
edge into our tree.
So we add e to the
set T, and then
we have to represent
the fact that we just
merged the connected
components of u and v,
and we do that
with a union call.
And if you're ever
wondering what
the heck do we use union-find
for, this is the answer.
The union-find data structure
was invented in order
to implement Kruskal's
algorithm faster, OK?
In fact, a lot of
data structures
come from graph algorithms.
The reason Fibonacci
heaps were invented
was because there was
Dijkstra's algorithm
and we wanted it to run fast.
So same deal here, you just
saw it in the reverse order.
First you saw union-find.
Now, union-find, you
know you can solve v
in alpha of n time, the
inverse Ackermann function,
super, super tiny, slow growing
function, smaller than log
log log log log log log.
Really small.
But we have this sorting,
which is kind of annoying.
So the overall
running time-- we'll
worry about correctness
in a moment.
We have to sort--
to sort E by weight.
So I'll just call
that's sort of E.
Then we have to do some unions.
I guess for every edge,
potentially, we do a union.
I'll just write E times alpha
of v. And then we have to do,
well, we also have to
find-sets, but same deal.
So find-set and union
cost alpha amortized,
so the total cost for
doing this for all edges
is going to be the number
of edges times alpha,
and then there's like plus v,
I guess, but that's smaller.
That's a connected graph.
So other than the sorting time,
this algorithm is really good.
It's faster.
But if you're sorting
by an n log n algorithm,
this is not so great.
That's how it goes.
I think you can reduce this to
sorting just v things, instead
of E things, with a
little bit of effort,
like doing a select operation.
But when this algorithm
is really good
is if your weights are integers.
If You have weights, let's
say weight of e is 0 or 1
or, say, n to the c,
for some constant c,
then I can use rate x
sort, linear time sorting,
and then this will
be linear time,
and I'm only paying
E times alpha.
So if you have
reasonably small weights,
Kruskal's algorithm is better.
Otherwise, I guess you
prefer Prim's algorithm.
But either away.
I actually used a variation
of this algorithm recently.
If you want to generate
a random spanning tree,
then you can use exactly
the same algorithm.
You pick a random manage that
you haven't picked already, you
see, can I add this
edge with this test?
If you can, add it and repeat.
That will give you a
random spanning tree.
It will generate all spanning
trees uniform leap likely.
So that's a fun fact,
useful thing for union-find.
Let me tell you briefly
about correctness.
Again, we proved correctness
with an invariant.
Claim that at all
times the tree T
of edges that
we've picked so far
is contained in some minimum
spanning tree, T star.
T start is going to
change, but I always
want the edges I've chosen to be
inside a minimum spanning tree.
Again, we can prove
this by induction.
So assume by induction
that this is true
so far, and then suppose that
we're adding an edge here.
So we're converting T into
T prime, which is T union e.
By the data structural
setup, I know
that the endpoints
of e, u, and v
are in different
connected components.
In general, what my
picture looks like,
is I have some various
connected components,
maybe there's a single
vertex, whatever.
I've built a minimum
spanning tree for each one.
I built some tree,
and I actually
know that these trees are
contained in one global minimum
spanning tree.
OK, and now we're
looking at an edge that
goes from some vertex u
in one connected component
to some vertex v in a
different connected component.
This is our edge e.
That's our setup.
Because the union-find
data structure
maintains connected
components, that's
another invariant to prove.
We're considering adding
this edge, which connects two
different connected components.
So I want to use the greedy
choice property with some S.
What should S be?
I want e to cross a cut,
so what's a good cut?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The
connected component
of u and then everything else.
ERIK DEMAINE:
Connected component
of u and everything else?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ERIK DEMAINE: That
would work, which
is also the opposite of the
connected component containing
v. There are many
choices that work.
I could take basically
this cut, which
is the connected component
of you with everything
else versus the
connected component of v.
I could take this cut, which
is the connected component of u
only versus everybody else.
Either of those will work.
Good.
Good curve, all right.
So let's say S equals the
connected component of u,
or connected component of v.
e crosses that, all right?
Because it goes from u to
v, and u is on one side,
v is on the other side.
I wanted to include an
entire connected component
because when I apply the
greedy choice property,
I modify T star,
and I don't want
to modify, I don't want to
delete any of these edges that
are already in my
connected components,
that I've already put in there.
But if I choose my
cut to just be this,
I know that the edge
that I potentially remove
will cross this
cut, which means it
goes between connected
components, which means
I haven't added that yet to T.
So when I apply this
greedy choice property,
I'm not deleting anything
from T. Everything that
was in T is still in T star.
So that tells me that T prime
is contained in T star prime.
The new T star that I get
when I apply the cut and paste
argument, I modify
T star potentially
by removing one edge
and putting e in.
And the edge that
I remove was not
already in T, which means
I preserve this part,
but I also get that
my new edge e is
in the minimum spanning tree.
And so that's how you prove
by induction that at all times
the edges that you've
chosen so far are in T star.
Actually, to apply the
greedy choice property,
I need not only that e is cut--
sorry, that e crosses the cut,
I also need that e
is the minimum weight
edge crossing the cut.
That's a little more
argument to prove.
The rough idea is
that if you forget
about the edges we've
already dealt with,
e is the globally
minimum weight edge.
OK, but what about the edges
we've already dealt with?
Some of them are in the tree.
The edges that are in
these-- that are in T, those
obviously don't cross the cut.
That's how we designed the cut.
The cup was designed
not to cross,
not two separate any of
these connected components.
So all the edges that we've
added to T, those are OK.
They're not related to the
edges that cross this cut.
But we may have already
considered some lower weight
edges that we didn't add to T.
If we didn't add an edge to T,
that means actually they
were in the same set, which
means also those are-- I'm going
to use my other color, blue.
Those are extra
edges in here that
are inside a
connected component,
have smaller weight
than e, but they're
inside the connected component.
So again, they're not crossed.
So they don't cross
the cut, rather.
So e is basically the
first edge that we're
considering that
crosses this cut,
because otherwise we would have
added that other edge first.
So here, we have to do sort
of the greedy argument again,
considering edges
by weight and e
is going to be the
first edge that
crosses this
particular cut, which
is this connected component
versus everyone else.
So e has to be the minimum
weight edge crossing the cut,
so the greedy choice
property applies.
So we can put e in the
minimum spanning tree,
and this algorithm is correct.
OK?
So we've used that lemma
a zillion times by now.
That's minimum spanning
tree and nearly linear time.